are you a webmaster with a slow janky or  frozen website  it sounds like you might have a memory  leak you see normally a javascript app  allocates memory to the heap  uses it then disposes of it  automatically with the garbage collector  but if your code references  objects that are no longer needed then  the garbage collector can't do its job  go to the performance panel in chrome  dev tools and hit record  as you use your website it records cpu  usage frames per second and takes a  bunch of screenshots along the way  but we're interested in this blue line  which shows the amount of memory in the  heap if it goes up up and up you may  want to go to the memory tab in chrome  record a heap snapshot and inspect the  actual values in it that's how you find  a memory leak now it's up to you to fix  it